There's so many new beauty releases
happening all the time,
so we gathered some of
the most hyped products
from December to test for ourselves.
We're starting off with
these Infinite Chrome Flakes
from Danessa Myricks.
This product is so interesting.
I thought it would be more like a gel,
but it's actually this super
liquidy and flaky formula,
which made me really nervous.
I used a brush to apply it
and the way the color shifts
with these flakes is unreal.
It was kind of hard to get it to show
all of the colors on camera,
but you can see it here
on this hand swatch I did.
It's so cool.
It is supposed to have that texture,
so if you hate that, don't get this,
but I like the effect, and
I actually got no fallout.
Like, once it dried, it did not move.
It does have a slight tightening
feeling as it's drying,
but once it was fully dry,
it was totally comfortable on the eyes.
I have a Patrick Ta blush
that I already love,
so I knew I would love this blush palette.
It comes with three shades
in both cream and powder formulas.
This Barbie pink color was speaking to me,
so I went for that one.
The pigment in these
blushes is incredible.
Like, you can really build
these up, no problem.
The cream blush blends really
well on top of foundation,
but I did get some patchiness
when I went over it with the powder one.
I think you just need to be careful
with how much pressure you're using.
I'm super heavy-handed
when it comes to my makeup.
And make sure you're tapping
the blush in and not swiping.
I think I prefer to wear the
cream and powder separately
rather than layered, but I
love the formulas of both.
This is the Moira Diamond
Daze Liquid Shadow.
I thought I was going to love these,
because I've seen so
many people try them out,
and they look amazing,
really great price point,
but I could not get this
liquid shadow to behave.
At first, I thought I could apply it
and then blend it out with my finger,
but that was just
removing all the product.
So then I just applied
it with the applicator
like the instructions said,
but I had all these harsh edges
I just could not blend out.
It's giving Monster High.
It's giving ghouls and goblins.
But nevertheless, she persisted,
and I tried it out a third time,
and it looked better, but not great.
I'm not a liquid shadow kind of person,
so it could just be me,
but I've never tried a liquid shadow
that's this difficult to use.
Please tell me what I'm doing wrong.
You guys keep selling this out,
but I finally, finally got my hands
on the Charlotte Tilbury
Glowgasm Beauty Light Wand
in Pinkgasm,
which is the blushy pink shade
everyone is obsessed with.
I'm going to say this:
The girls weren't lying.
It's so, so good.
Blending it was so effortless.
It gives your cheeks this
glowy, flush look. Oh, my God.
And none of the foundation
underneath moved or got patchy,
and I had already powdered
my face at this point.
The second this comes
back in stock, get it.
Next up is a product I
actually already use,
the Milk Hydro Grip setting spray.
Mine is very well loved.
This is overall a really
nice setting spray.
It has more of a dewy finish to it,
so it melts makeup powders
really nicely into your skin,
but it also does help
the makeup last longer.
I like to spray this in layers
at different parts of
the application process
to really make sure nothing is
going to move around too much.
The transfer is super minimal,
if you do get any at all,
and I just really like how my skin looks
when I use this setting spray.
This is one of the coolest
products I've tried
in a really long time.
This is the Genlen Beauty Facemud,
and it's this super matte, mousse-y cream
that can be applied to your
eyes, lips, and cheeks.
It was kind of intimidating at first
because it's so pigmented
-- like, look at that --
but it was way easier to
control than I thought.
You just go in little by little.
You can go from like a wash of color,
like I did on my eyes and cheeks,
to full-color payoff
like I did on my lips.
It didn't remove any of the
product I already had on,
and I don't know, it's just
unique and easy to use.
And I love the velvety finish it has.